[MUSIC PLAYING]
WOODROW HARTZOG: Thank
you all for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for the opportunity
to come speak here.
Today, I'm going to be speaking
with you about my book,
"Privacy's Blueprint--
The Battle to Control the
Design of New Technologies."
And I really want to start
off with a series of stories
to tell you a little bit
about what the book is about.
So many of you, if
not most of you,
are familiar with the Cambridge
Analytica-Facebook dust
up, as it were.
And there was a
lot going on there
where lots of information that
was taken from Facebook that
eventually made its way towards
Cambridge Analytica and then
outward, and it caused
a huge public discussion
about privacy and platforms.
And there was a lot going
on built in with that,
but one of the most
interesting things
was the fact that there was a
big debate about whether this
was originally what
they referred to as
a breach or something else.
And one of the things
that sort of came up,
and one of the things that
indeed the platform actually
said is that
permission was actually
granted through the
privacy settings
to have this sort of information
given to third-party apps.
And in fact it wasn't
just the one app
that was collecting
lots of information.
This was actually a
relatively common practice
that people were agreeing to.
But if you actually start to
dig in and think about, well,
what was actually
agreed to and what
did it look like, you
realized it was sort
of one small little
option nested within lots
of other small little
options that existed,
and while you may technically
have agreed to it,
it was sort of binary
and relatively hidden.
And so it resulted
in a lot of confusion
because the people that
seemed to be angry about it
said, well, wait a second,
I didn't agree to that.
And then, of course, they
were shown exactly where
they did, and said, OK.
Well, maybe that
wasn't the best thing.
The second story I
want to talk about,
this is a still taken from
an internet-connected baby
monitor.
And the most disturbing
thing about this--
and this was disturbing
in and of itself--
isn't that there's
this one still
but rather there's an entire
search engine dedicated
to finding these sorts of stills
because these sorts of devices
are so routinely compromised
and so easy to take control
of that there's actually an
entire collection of them
online, which I thought was
also relatively disturbing.
And then the third story
that I wanted to talk about
was what many of you may have
been familiar with, which
is the dispute between the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
and Apple over whether to
build in some sort of bypass
to its encryption scheme
and authentication protocol
to allow it to access the phone
of the San Bernardino shooter.
Now what do these three
things have in common?
They all are stories
about the design
of information technologies.
And in the book, I focus
on how things are built
and the way in which
they affect our privacy.
And I want to make
three points today,
and I try to make three
larger points in the book.
One, design matters for privacy.
And more than that--
which may seem
relatively evident--
we need to have a
better conversation
to explore why design matters
and how design matters
for our privacy because I
think it matters more than what
most people regularly consider.
Two, and this is the main
thesis of the book which
is why it's in bold, which is
that privacy laws should take
design more seriously,
and not just the law
but also industry policy,
industry standards,
industry norms.
We focus a lot on personal data.
What data's being collected?
How is it being used?
Who is it being shared with?
We focus a lot
about transparency,
but I argue that
actually there's a gap.
There's a huge area within
which design affects
a lot of what people consider
their personal privacy
interests that we don't
regularly talk about
in law and in industry policy.
And three-- and this is perhaps
one of the more controversial
aspects of the book--
a design agenda
for law and policy
should have roots in consumer
protection and surveillance
law, not the standard
data-protection framework that
is becoming incredibly
popular through frameworks
like the GDPR, which everyone
is probably at least mildly
aware of given the
thousands of emails
that you received
somewhere around late April
that says we've
updated our terms.
And it's built around
this model that
tends to prioritize certain
kinds of data collection
and processing rules I think
at the expense of ignoring
some nuances about the ways
in which design actually
controls our privacy.
So, let me expand upon
these three points.
One, design matters for privacy.
What do I mean by that?
I mean that design
matters for privacy
because it is everywhere,
because it is power,
and because it is political.
First, design is everywhere.
Many people might
recognize what this is.
Does anyone know what this is?
Has anyone seen this before?
It is a promo user interface,
early user interface
for the app Snapchat.
Now if you were to look
at this knowing nothing--
sometimes I give
this talk and I speak
with people that haven't
used technology that much
or are only sort of casual
users of a lot of apps,
and so they've never
seen this at all.
And so I like to
sort of pause and I
say if you had never seen
this before, what would
you think this user interface
is designed to accomplish?
And some of the usual
answers I get are, well, it's
probably something that
relates to taking and sending
of a picture.
We can tell that exists
for-- we saw the timer here.
Where does the timer probably
do, if we had to guess?
Yeah, it makes the picture
disappear after maybe
a certain amount of time.
We see the scroll wheel
that we can select,
so we clearly have options.
It's clearly meant not just
for taking photos and storing
them but for sharing them.
We can tell because
we see a send button
and it's got the little arrow.
And then one of my favorite
things about this user
interface and one of the most
demonstrative sort of signals
that we see about the way
in which this is supposed
to be used, what do you
think this particular app,
just looking at this,
what kinds of pictures
do you think the app is
inviting you to send?
Naughty pictures, right?
Originally this is how Snapchat
was sort of perceived publicly.
And you can't blame
them because, look,
we've got an incredibly
carefully cropped little square
here where we can't tell whether
these young women are clothed
or not.
They're having fun.
And the implicit message
built in through every aspect
of design of this
user interfaces
is that you can trust this app
with things that you might not
trust in more-permanent
sorts of social media
because it goes away.
It is safer than if
you were to use, say,
some other service where the
pictures are stored forever.
And all of this is conveyed
with less than three words.
It's all signals.
It's all things
that we intuitively
seem to understand through
the design of information
technologies.
And I started looking for
examples for this book,
and once you start
to look for examples
of the ways in which design
affects your privacy,
you see them all over the place,
and not just in obvious ways
but in subtle ways.
So I don't have to
tell everybody here
what this technology is,
and there were some design
decisions that went
into Google Glass
that I thought were
incredibly interesting.
The most obvious
privacy-relevant feature
for Google Glass is what?
AUDIENCE: The
camera on the front.
WOODROW HARTZOG: The
camera on the front, right?
It's literally staring
straight at us.
But that's not the
design feature--
I mean, I guess you
could have designed Glass
without the camera.
That was a design decision that
implicated people's privacy
because it's able
to be surveilled.
But of course the
counterargument
to that is this
camera doesn't really
do a lot that
isn't already being
done by another camera,
the one that everyone
has in their phones.
And so the design
decision that's
relevant for Google Glass is
not just that there's a camera
but that the camera is
always potentially visible.
Now there's a small
transaction cost,
but it's significant
at scale, which
is in order to take a picture
with our normal phones
we have to reach into our
phone, pull it out, open it up.
We fiddle with it.
We aim it, and then
we take the photo.
Now that doesn't seem like
a lot on a per-time basis,
but that small transaction
cost actually, I think,
has a tendency to make
people feel more comfortable
with the fact that
everyone is carrying
around a sort of
persistent surveillance
device in their
pockets all the time,
whereas Glass was met with
much more resistance, right?
People tended to be more
uncomfortable with it
than they did with their phones.
I think the reason why is
because the camera was always
there.
The transaction cost of
having to dig into your pocket
was suddenly gone
and all you had to do
was utter a command or sort
of readily activate it.
There was another
design decision
that I thought was really
relevant to Google Glass that
didn't get a lot of attention,
but it's my understanding
that Glass did not
provide support
for facial-recognition
technologies, which
was an interesting
design decision and one
that I think also had privacy
implications, positive privacy
implications.
I don't have to tell anyone here
what this symbol is as well,
but for those that
aren't familiar,
this is the symbol
of Incognito mode.
When you open up Google
Chrome's browser and you go
into incognito mode you see--
or at one point.
I believe the icon
has now changed--
but at one point
you saw this icon.
And I always like
to ask people--
this is it this is
a design, right?
It's a signal to people.
And if you were to just
see this, what would
you think the signal was?
What is this meant to convey?
AUDIENCE: Concealment.
WOODROW HARTZOG: I'm sorry?
WOODROW HARTZOG:
Concealment, right,
which of course is the purpose.
I mean, it's called
Incognito mode.
And we've got, it seems, like a
sort of classic 1940s gumshoe,
someone that doesn't
want to be seen.
They can put their collar up.
They've got a hat that they can
pull down low, maybe glasses.
Again, the implicit message
just from looking at this
is that you're safer
if you want to hide.
Now of course that's not exactly
how Incognito mode works,
right?
And indeed when you
open up Incognito mode
you've got a list of things.
They say, by the way, here are
all the people that can still
see you when using
Incognito mode, which
is a very important disclosure.
But absent that you
might think, oh, well,
I'm using the safe browser,
the browser that doesn't record
any history of me at all.
It's completely incognito.
And so without that, I
think, important disclosure,
this design would tend to
shape people's expectations.
And so when you
look around you tend
to see these sort
of design decisions
everywhere that tend to be
relevant for people's decisions
about what to disclose,
how much to disclose,
and how safe they
are in disclosing.
Now the second point that
I want to make about design
is that design is power.
One of my favorite experiments
that I talk a little bit
about in the book was done
by Leslie John, Alesandro
Acquisti, and George Loewenstein
at Carnegie Mellon University.
And they got several
people in to answer
this series of questions
in a survey on a screen.
And they sat down and
they were presented
with a screen like
this, and they
asked them a number of
different questions,
and this is just a snapshot.
And the questions ranged
from sort of banal
to relatively intimate
to incredibly intimate.
And this is just a short
little snapshot here.
They said, have you
ever smoked marijuana?
Have you ever cheated
while in a relationship?
Have you ever
driven when you were
pretty sure you were over the
legal blood alcohol level,
asking you to admit
to committing a crime.
Now what's the first
thing that you notice
when I put this screen up?
How BAD are U???
And so there were a series of
design decisions that I think
were particularly relevant here.
One is the fact that BAD
is sort of capitalized.
And then they use the sort of
cutesy U sort of text speak.
How BAD are U???
Multiple question marks,
which is indicative of what--
youth, right, exuberance.
What else do we have
relevant to design here?
AUDIENCE: The logo.
WOODROW HARTZOG:
The logo, right?
It's a devil, but
it's not a bad devil.
It's like an emoji
devil, like a cute devil.
There's one other
design decision
that I thought was
really interesting.
AUDIENCE: Font.
WOODROW HARTZOG: The font.
It is written in
Comic Sans, and no one
in the history of
the world has taken
anything seriously written
in Comic Sans font, right?
And the overall
implication, of course,
of all of these
design decisions,
despite asking incredibly
intimate questions, questions
that can implicate you in a
crime, is that how bad are you?
You're bad.
You know you're bad.
Everyone's just a
little bit bad, right?
That's sort of the implication
of every single design
feature built into this.
And then, of course,
the control group
they had looked like this.
Gone is the Comic Sans font
replaced with this very formal
sans serif font.
Gone is our cute little
question about how BAD are U,
and now it's just replaced
with the imprimatur
of Carnegie Mellon University,
a very prestigious university.
But the questions
remained exactly the same.
And I want to read
directly because I
don't want to misquote the
results of their study,
but they call this the
frivolous-looking interface
in this the
non-frivolous-looking
interface.
And they found that relative
to the non-frivolous interface,
participants in the
frivolous-looking survey
that asked identical
questions were,
on average, 1.7 times more
likely to admit having
engaged in risky behaviors.
For example, a participant in
the frivolous-looking survey
was, on average, 2.03
times more likely
to admit having ever taken
nude pictures of himself
or a partner.
And the authors conclude,
"People, it seems,
feel more comfortable
providing personal information
on unprofessional sites that
are arguably particularly
likely to misuse it."
Design is power.
Design doesn't necessarily
dictate behavior
but it channels it.
Every single design decision
makes a certain reality
more or less likely.
And so it provides an
incredible amount of power.
And that leads me to
my third point, which
is that design is political.
Design is always political.
And when I say political
I don't mean political
in terms of Capitol Hill.
I mean political in terms of
the distribution of power.
So I give this talk a
little, and sometimes
in response people will come
up afterwards and they'll say,
why are you targeting
design as something
that we should be
focused about in law?
Instead of targeting the tools
that we use to create problems,
why don't we target the
harmful problems themselves?
One of the examples that's
been put forth recently
is a knife can be
used for good or bad,
but we don't ban knives.
Instead we say you can't
use a knife to stab someone,
but you can use it to cut food.
And so it's always some
version of the argument
that there are no bad
technologies, only bad uses
of those technologies,
and that should
be the focus of our
policy and law efforts.
But I think that that actually
tends to cut against the fact
that I don't think that
there's such a thing
as a neutral technology.
Given the fact that every
single design decision
is meant to affect the world--
that's what design is.
It's a series of decisions
that get reflected
in some sort of
substance that affects
the world in some
particular way.
Then there's no such thing
as neutral technologies.
Even ignoring
certain realities is
an acceptance of those
realities in a certain sense.
And so we cannot ignore
technology and the role
of design in law and policy.
We have to confront it head on.
And there may be reasons
why we explicitly
decide not to have rules
against legislating technology.
We don't want regulators
for example dictating
from top to bottom every
single design decision
in a ham-fisted way because it's
difficult to think that they
would know better how to build
a lot of particular technologies
than people that live it.
But that too has its
own costs, and we
need to be specific about
which costs we want to embrace
and how to better balance them
with the full range of concerns
that we have.
And the only way that
we're going to do that
is if we explicitly embrace
the design of technology
and how that is powerful
in our laws and policies.
So that leads me
to my next point,
which is that privacy law should
take design more seriously
because right now it doesn't.
It may seem like it
relatively does and there
may be some in this room
or listening in online
that have had experience
dealing with regulators
and with the European Union
and the General Data Protection
Regulation that deal with
privacy by design and privacy
by default, but actually I
will argue that, largely,
privacy law and privacy policy
and the rules that we have even
internally about privacy
have a major design gap.
So I teach privacy law at
Northeastern University.
And it's a whole
semester-long course,
but it turns out there are
basically only three privacy
rules that you have to follow.
And so I can save you
all a lot of money
if you're interested in
taking a privacy-law course.
I'm just going to
summarize it now.
One of the rules is follow the
Fair Information Practices.
This is the underlying ethos
of the entire General Data
Protection Regulation.
It's the idea behind statutes
that you are probably
very familiar with like the
Fair Credit Reporting Act,
or even HIPAA has a sense of
follow the Fair Information
Practices.
And the Fair
Information Practices
are things that
are so fundamental
to our understanding of
fairness with data processing
that you probably have
already internalized them
without thinking about them.
For example, people should have
control over their information.
Databases should be transparent
about what they're collecting.
They should give people notice
about what they're collecting
and the ability to delete
information or correct
information.
You should only
collect what you need,
and you should
delete it when you're
done with it, the
data-minimization principle.
There's the principle
of accountability,
that we should be
accountable for these rules.
There's the
principle that people
should have certain sort of
access rights or portability
rights to their data.
These are all things
that we've been talking
about for a long
time, and they all
started with the Fair
Information Practices, which
actually originated in
the mid and late 1970s
and then made their
way through and now are
as close as the world has
come to a common language
of privacy, which is pretty
remarkable when you consider
all the varying different
cultural connotations that play
into conceptions of privacy.
The fact that we
have a basic set
of rules on how to fairly
collect and process data
is remarkable.
And the FIPs are important.
They're necessary.
But here's the
problem with the FIPs.
They look like this.
This is the way
in which they get
reflected because if
you look at the FIPs,
it almost always boils down
to this idea of control.
If you ask the CEOs
of every major tech
company in the United
States and the world
how do you respect the
privacy of your users,
I'd bet money that they
would almost all respond
with some version of we
put people in control
of their own information.
This is one of the most dominant
conceptualization of privacy
in the United States
and around the world,
the idea being that
if we give users
control of their
information, then
they get to decide
for themselves
what they want to do
with their information
and what they're OK with.
They do a risk calculation.
And if they are given
that control, then
if they exercise
it then presumably
the giving of that control
is enough to justify
certain sorts of data practices
because people approve it.
They have control over it.
Data subjects' autonomy
in theory is respected.
The platform
collecting information
has done its moral duty
under this conceptualization
by offering the control, and
we can all proceed together.
And here's the
problem with that,
and here's the problem
of thinking privacy
in terms of control generally,
which is really popular
not just in industry.
Governments conceptualize
privacy as control.
Advocates conceptualize
It is by far, probably, the most
popular way to define privacy.
I teach privacy law,
and on the first day
I ask my students to
write out what privacy
is and say what is privacy?
And then we go around the room.
I have 20 to 30 students,
and I usually get around
5 to 10 different
answers, but almost always
the most popular
response is control
over personal information.
But again, the way that control
is reflected in practice
is through design.
It is through buttons,
toggle switches,
which in theory is still fine.
Everyone knows what this is.
Green means yes.
Gray means no.
It's a toggle switch.
Can Google Maps collect your
geolocation information?
Green means yes.
Gray means no.
Yes.
I have exercised control.
I have made a decision.
Privacy is respected.
Onward we go.
Except, of course,
it doesn't always
work out like that because it
never looks just like that,
does it?
we have a series of decisions
to make because we don't want
the decision to be just binary.
If it's too binary,
it's too abstracted.
Privacy is complicated.
There are nuances.
Yes/no doesn't give
enough choices.
So we say, OK, I
need lots of choices.
I want nuance.
This is the inherent
tension in defining privacy
as control is give me nuance.
So tech companies respond and
they say, OK, we'll give you
lots of different choices.
Rather than just sort
of one on/off binary
we'll give you lots of choices.
Except, of course, that
means that users are now
responsible for
analyzing those choices.
And you say, OK, I've got
the Find My iPad button
and location-based alerts.
I guess that's good.
Location-based iAds, I
don't know what that means.
Share my location,
green, OK, I guess.
I guess I'll try to
figure that one out.
Wi-Fi network, I don't
know what that button does,
but I guess it's OK.
Diagnostics and usage, popular
near me, I guess that's good.
And we have to make all of
these sort of implicit risk
calculations over
and over again,
which is costly in terms
of personal resources
because people have
limited amounts of time.
And so we go through--
OK, so let's say
we look at this.
Design is set up
in this way for us
to effectuate the
control that we're given.
We do it and we say,
phew, I think I'm good.
I think I've set my settings
the way I want them.
And then we take a deep
breath and we back up
and we say, oh dear.
I've got lots of buttons
to press over and over.
And when the settings change,
I've got to update them again.
The problem with thinking about
privacy in terms of control
is that people are gifted
with so much control
that they choke on it.
And it becomes, in practice,
a way for risk of loss
to be shifted on to users
because if you fail to exercise
that control, it's not the
problem of the company that
gave you the control, right?
They're giving you the options.
That's what you wanted.
And so there's an inherent
tension that almost is never
going to be resolved which
is if you abstract it away
and make control
easy, if you provide
one button for
all of our issues,
then it becomes too generalized.
There is too much
stuff washed in,
and so our ability to do
a meaningful risk calculus
is washed away.
But if you provide every
option under the sun,
then it becomes over burdensome.
It's a DDoS attack on our
brain, and there's no way
that we can respond at scale.
And so control, I think,
is actually fundamentally
one of the misguided,
actually, ways
to think about privacy in
the modern data ecosystem
because it's never
going to work.
It just doesn't scale unless
we start having a conversation
about prioritizing control which
gets really interesting, which
we can talk about later.
So there's this massive
design gap in follow the FIPs,
this ethic that we
follow in all privacy law
and in all industry
sort of rules, which
is you should give people
control, because design is
leveraged to, instead of
being autonomy enhancing,
it actually is autonomy
corrosive because we've
given all these choices.
We're sort of burdened
in them, or it's
abstracted away to the point
where it's meaningless.
That's rule one.
Rule two is do not lie.
Relatively simple rule, right?
The Federal Trade
Commission, which
is the nation's top
regulator of privacy,
has authority to regulate unfair
and deceptive trade practices.
And as part of its regulation
it has one major rule
which is don't lie to people.
That sounds relatively easy.
The problem with the
do-not-lie ethos, of course,
is one of the similar problems
to transparency and control
generally which is you can put
technical truths in a place
that nobody's
going to read them.
And we all know where
you put the things where
you want nobody to read it.
Where do we put it?
If I want to be sure to
put something in a place
where I know no user is
ever going to see it,
where am I going to stick it?
AUDIENCE: The privacy policy.
WOODROW HARTZOG: The privacy
policy or the terms of use.
I do this for a living.
I am a privacy law professor,
and I cannot scroll through
the terms of use quick
enough to get to I Agree
because of course there's
no way that, at scale,
anyone could
collectively read them.
We'd have to take two days
off of vacation a year just
to read all the privacy
policies we come into.
And so do not lie can also get
circumvented through design
through putting it
in a place where
technical truth is ignored.
And then there's the
do not harm ethic.
That's the last one.
So the Federal Trade
Commission also
says don't engage in
unfair trade practices that
harm users in a way that's
not avoidable by the users
themselves and in
a way that's not
outbalanced by countervailing
benefits to the consumer.
That's the sort
of test they use.
But of course the
do-not-harm ethic
is also easily
subverted through design
because in the modern
age the threshold
for harm to rise to a legal
violation is sort of high.
If you're going to bring a
lawsuit against a company,
then you don't want
the harm to be this
is creepy, which is some
of the things that happen.
And creepy is not a real word
that has boundaries around it.
What is creepy?
Lots of things get
possibly creepy,
but that varies wildly
across the spectrum.
And so the law, and
in many ways rightly,
actually says you've got to
have a real tangible harm here.
You've got to have some
sort of financial harm.
Someone stole your identity.
Someone stole your money.
Or you have to have some
sort of clear emotional harm,
and often it is your naked
body was exposed publicly
or something very visceral
and something that
has a clear boundary to it.
But, of course,
many of the sorts
of things that people
quantify as privacy
harms in the modern
age is not actually
those sorts of visceral harms,
which can be relatively rare,
but rather it's
a little bit more
of a death by a thousand cuts.
We reveal a little bit
of information here
and we trickle a little bit of
information there, none of it
which rises to the
level of what we would
consider to be a privacy harm.
But collectively
we look up one day
and we all become vulnerable.
And we all see that we've gone
down this road without actually
having any one
particular violation,
yet here we are with
lots of our information
sort of exposed that
could ultimately
be leveraged against us.
And so design also
sort of does that
through the way in
which we encourage
short little amounts
of information
to be disclosed here and there.
Oh, it's just a little
information here.
It's just a little
information there.
But collectively it
becomes a big issue.
So at this point you may be
saying, all right smart guy.
Well, if we've got
the problems, what
are we going to do about it?
And that actually
is the next part
of the book which is where I
propose a theory of privacy law
and design.
And the theory is actually
built around values, boundaries,
and tools.
And the values that I advocate
for are actually not control.
Even though that's the
dominant framework,
I think there are better
values that we can embrace
not only that will give
US industry and US law
a much clearer
identity with respect
to protecting
personal information
but also one that doesn't
sort of inherently
have this tension where
you have to choose
between a meaningless
abstraction
or overwhelming
nuance, and that's
trust, obscurity, and autonomy.
In other words, I argue that our
law and policy should encourage
design that is trustworthy,
that promotes or at least values
obscurity, and
enhances autonomy.
Now what do I mean by that?
Trust, I think, is one of
the most important values
in the modern age with
respect to the disclosure
of personal information
in platforms.
Trust is key for commerce.
Trust is key for personal
relationships and intimacy.
Trust is key for
self-exploration.
We tend not to disclose
to other people
in an attempt to sort
of figure out who
we are unless we trust those.
If everything we say
can be used against us,
then we tend not to sort of
engage in self-exploration.
And so our design
should reflect that.
Our design should reflect
a sense of discretion--
not necessarily confidentiality,
but just discretion.
We don't disclose
everything all the time.
This can be deidentification.
This can be disclosure
within a limited community.
It should encourage a
sense of protection.
Now this is a
little more obvious,
right, which is don't store
people's passwords in cleartext
and salt and hash and
let's encrypt traffic.
We should protect the data.
This is what we will refer
to maybe as data security.
A sense of honesty--
and honesty is different
from transparency.
Transparency often
gets touted as, look,
we've opened up
the books to you.
You can look inside and you
can see whatever is available,
but that's actually different
than what I would consider
to be acting honestly.
Honestly is affirmatively
disclosing the things
that users want to
know that maybe you
would prefer not to tell them
but they should probably know.
In other words, it's
a little bit more
of affirmative
obligation as a warning
rather than full transparency.
And then finally-- and this
is the hard one with respect
to trust--
design should be
loyal to the user.
And what I mean by
that is it shouldn't
elevate the interests of
the platform unreasonably
or in unreasonable ways over the
interests of the data subject,
and we can talk about what
I mean by that in a minute.
And that would be
trustworthy design,
design that is discrete,
protective, honest, and loyal.
Now another sort
of design choice
which isn't quite as
established in law and policy
is the value of obscurity.
Obscurity is the idea
that when information
is hard or unlikely to be
found or understood then
it is, to a relative
degree, safe.
We rely upon zones of
obscurity all the time
in our everyday lives, and
we don't even realize it.
How many people
here have eaten out
at a restaurant within
the last two weeks?
A number of people.
Do any of you remember who
was sitting two tables away
from you?
Probably not.
You were in public.
Everyone could see you, but
of course we've long since
deleted that information.
I flew here yesterday
on an airplane.
I don't remember what the
person sitting next to me
looked like even though
it was in public,
and we do this to help
sort of prevent cognitive
overburdening.
And we rely upon
this risk calculus
all the time to make decisions.
When I'm walking out in
public, if you quickly
want to sort of scratch
in a delicate place
and you look around
and no one's looking,
you do it even though maybe if
that were posted on the Times
Square jumbotron then you would
have second thoughts about it,
but the odds of that
are incredibly small.
When you go shopping in a
grocery store or a drug store,
you're in public.
You're picking out
things that are delicate,
but the odds that
someone is standing right
behind you writing down every
single thing that you purchase
is incredibly low, and the
odds of that ever coming back
to hurt you is also
incredibly low.
So we value obscurity,
and the harm
comes when our obscurity
is taken away from us
in dramatic ways.
In other words, there are
lurches, obscurity lurches.
I've written very critically
about facial-recognition
technologies, and one
of the reasons why is I
view it as an incredible
obscurity lurch.
Our faces, while public,
basically allow us still
to be relatively private
as we walk in a crowd,
but facial-recognition
technologies
threaten that ability.
It represents a dramatic
obscurity lurch.
And online, some
of my research is
focused on there are things
that can obscure you or make you
more obvious like
search visibility,
unprotected access, whether
we protect something
with a password,
whether someone uses
their real name or a pseudonym
or no identifier at all,
and whether things are clear.
Sometimes things are obscure
because people lack the context
to make sense of them.
If I were to tell you all
right now, hey, by the way
I just got the test results
back, it's positive,
you would have no
idea what that meant.
It's obscure to you
and it's safe to me
because you have no
idea what that means.
But if you had the back
story which is maybe
that my wife and I were trying
to conceive then you would say,
oh, I now understand.
This is sort of hiding in
plain sight with content.
And so there are ways in which
we can obscure information
and preserve that obscurity.
And then finally the value that
I advocate for is autonomy.
Now autonomy is
different than control.
Control can serve autonomy--
the right to be free from
external interference,
the right to
self-determination--
but too much control actually
threatens that autonomy.
So I argue that a
better value to embrace
is autonomy rather than control.
All right, and so that
leads me to the final part
of the book where I argue that a
design agenda should have roots
in consumer protection
and surveillance law
rather than saying, well, the
Fair Information Practices
which everybody accepts are the
thing that we should adhere to.
If you look, I say
there are actually
other areas of the law that
have thought this out, that
have taken design seriously, and
I propose sorts of boundaries
to avoid deceptive
design, abusive design,
and dangerous design.
Deceptive design is
something that we relatively
are doing a good
job with, both, I
think, within industry
and within policy
in terms of not outright
deceiving people.
It says this is Path complaints
filed by the Federal Trade
Commission where add
friends actually didn't just
allow you to add friends but
actually automatically sort of
went in and scooped up
the entire contact list.
And then there's also
the idea that maybe we
should avoid
abusive design which
is deleveraging of people's
own limitations against them.
And this happens sometimes
in everyday life.
We tend to sort of leverage
people's own limitations
against them, but
it's another thing
entirely to build an
entire machine built
to leverage people's own
limitations against them.
This is an example of different
differential pricing based
on people's personal
characteristics,
or the thing that made my
privacy-law students really mad
one year is the fact
that a certain travel
site could tell whether
you're using a PC or a Mac.
It would show the
cheaper hotel rooms
to the people using Windows PCs
and the more expensive hotel
rooms to the people using
Macs based on the assumption
that people that had
Macintoshes actually
had more had more money
and were more affluent.
But there are tons of examples.
So one of the
examples that pops up
when leveraging people's
own limitations against them
is our desire for conformity.
People have a strong desire
sort of to be with the group
or to do what
everyone else does,
and sometimes that can
be worked against us.
So this shows up
in the literature
around dark patterns, which is
a really interesting website.
And this is one where
it says get 10% off,
and then at the bottom
it says, "No, thanks.
I'd rather pay full price for
delicious tea," which they're
sort of shaming people, right?
Be like, oh, OK.
Well, I don't want to
be the sucker here.
And there are several other
examples where you see--
because people's voting records
tend to be public in most
states, some people have
actually leveraged that
and they said all your
neighbors voted and you didn't.
Here are the people that
voted and you didn't vote.
Look how irresponsible you are,
which is sort of a shaming.
Or one here which is at the
bottom it says, "No thanks.
I'm fine with losing customers."
No one here wants to
click that, right?
Now again, this is a very subtle
sort of manipulative technique,
but it's one that,
at scale, could tend
to be harmful in the right way.
Another example of using
people's own limitations
against them is the use of
double and triple negatives.
So here it's decline release
of directory information.
Note, most parents do
not choose this option.
So we've got lots of nots here.
I do not want the
release information.
So when you start layering
double and triple negatives,
then it's not lying.
It's not deceitful, but it's
leveraging people's inability
to sort of process the
double and triple negative.
I don't not never want
this information released.
And then finally there's
dangerous design.
Some designs are just
inherently dangerous.
This is a spy camera.
It's designed for more
or less one thing, which
is to catch people in
various states of undress
because it's a clothes hanger.
It's meant to be put in rooms
where people are taking clothes
on and off.
And I argue that that's
dangerous design.
As dangerous as surveillance
that you know about is,
I view surveillances
you don't know about
to be even more
potentially dangerous.
There are lots of potential
responses to this,
and I go into this in the
second part of the book--
soft responses,
moderate responses,
and robust responses.
So a soft response
is we don't have
to come in as regulators heavy
handed and say we're regulating
this to the hilt. Sometimes what
privacy needs is some funding.
It needs some innovation.
It needs some opportunity.
It needs standardization.
It needs educational
opportunities.
And so I argue for a
lot of different ways
to improve people's privacy
without passing some really
heavy-handed regulations.
Sometimes we need some
moderate responses.
Maybe judges just need to
be a little more sensitive
to the role the design
plays in shaping
people's expectations
and their choices,
and maybe regulators do too.
This is an example
of the padlock icon
which is ubiquitous online.
We use it all the time.
It is the physical
symbol of security,
but we don't really
question what it
means to people as much, right?
When people see the
padlock icon they usually
think they're safe or secure.
That's what a lock means.
But what does it really
mean on the practice?
And maybe there
are ways in which
these sort of padlock
icons might act
as sort of implicit promises.
And then finally
there may be a need
for heavy-handed regulations
in certain instances.
One of the things I've
argued for is in support
of the ban on spyware that we
have right now, which I think
can be used in really
malicious ways.
And then another thing that's
a little more controversial
is I've argued in favor
of moratoriums and bans
on facial-recognition
technology, which
I view as one of the most
uniquely dangerous surveillance
technologies ever invented.
And then the final
part of the book,
I lay out what this blueprint
of this design agenda
might look in three
different kinds
of contexts-- social media,
hide-and-seek technologies,
and the internet of
things, which is basically
just a plea to tech
companies to stop
connecting people's underwear
to the internet, which
is one of the things.
And with that, I would
love to go ahead and go
to the question-and-answer
period.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You've given some
examples of bad designs.
Can you give an example
of a good design,
particularly in the
area of providing
user autonomy as you described?
WOODROW HARTZOG: Oh,
OK, actually there
are several, I think,
very good designs.
One might be there are areas
in which-- so after I sort
of rail on control
a lot, there are
areas in which control might
actually be really useful.
I like the data-subject right--
I also sort of critiqued
the GDPR, but now
I'll backtrack on
that a little too--
data-subject rights
that allow you
to log in and review profiles.
Information that's
kept about you I think
are very useful because
they can be done
at the election of the user.
Dashboards, for
example, that allow
you to review
histories, locations,
I think those are very good.
My general principle is that
people should be protected
regardless of what they choose.
But if there are ways in which
they can exercise autonomy
on top of that baseline
level of protection,
then that should be encouraged.
There are also
small little things
that I like that a
lot of people actually
critique as not going
far enough but I
like because they're
obscurity protective.
For example, YouTube
released a tool
that allowed you to blur
people's faces I believe.
I love that tool.
And one of the reasons I
love it is because it's
obscurity protecting.
It's one that if you happen
to know the person who's
in the video then maybe
you would recognize them,
but to the world that's actually
a pretty good design, right?
So in other words, people
are largely protected.
We often don't want to be
protected from everybody, just
from certain sorts of risks.
The right to be forgotten is
one of these things where people
often want their name
disassociated with being
found for certain results.
They don't need the
information gone.
They just don't
want the HR person
who is reviewing
their application
for a job they want to find it.
And so there are
certain sorts of things
that can protect obscurity
in design like that,
and I think the YouTube
face-blurring video
is a great example of that.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you consider metadata
like derived data
for [INAUDIBLE] data?
How does that kind
of play into this?
And other people's data of me--
so there was the
Facebook thing I
think where other
people had data on me
and I won't be able to
see their data on me.
So, for instance, if they
had a phone number of me
but I never authorized Facebook
to have my phone number
but they had it, Facebook
now has my phone number
and I don't know that
Facebook has my phone number.
WOODROW HARTZOG:
The question is sort
of what is the role of
metadata in all of this,
and this is what I
think really illustrates
the limits of the control
conception of privacy
because so much is actually
out of our control.
A really good example
is genetic information.
So my sister got one of
the popular sort of tests
and gave away her
genetic information,
and I was really a
little uneasy about it
because I was like,
that's my information too,
and I've got no
control over that
at all, which is why I argue
that we should have less
reliance on control
because control ultimately
sort of becomes unraveled
at this stage right.
It's our inability
to control it.
This is where I argue for
the importance of trust.
This is where relationships
of trust matter.
Now there are costs to that.
So if we think of privacy
in terms of trust,
then inherently we've just
made this conceptualization
of privacy relational.
So then there are
advantages to that
in that now I can ask you
if you have metadata on me
or if a platform has
metadata on multiple people
to act in a certain way-- loyal,
for example, to not leverage
that information against me.
I don't think that just because
information is disclosed
your privacy is
necessarily gone.
I think that we
disclose information
within relationships
of trust all the time.
But what it does mean
is that sometimes there
are parties that have
no relationship that
have that information that
can then violate your privacy.
So data brokers would
be an obvious example
where they don't have a direct
relationship with the data
subject in ways that platforms
that collect information
directly do, but
they get information
from various streams.
And so my general
sense is that we
should have a baseline set of
rules that even apply to data
brokers but that a lot of our
issues with respect to metadata
and a lot of these
unraveling problems
can be solved through thinking
with privacy in terms of trust.
So just the fact that
you have it right
or that someone else has it
isn't the end of the story.
Rather, there are
now things that you
shouldn't be able to do
with that information.
AUDIENCE: We have a question
from the Dory from Cain.
I found that I quickly
learned to click
on those "I'm fine with
losing customers" buttons
because the pop up is
blocking the task I
was trying to complete.
What are some tips for
making sure people know
how to go back and change their
mind when it's no longer time
critical?
WOODROW HARTZOG: Again,
not to make everything
an illustration of the limits
of the control conceptualization
of privacy, but often when
we think of consent, consent
is implemented in
sort of binary terms.
Like I agree to this, and then
once that it's gotten then
it sort of in perpetuity
exists and you
don't have to
re-ask for it again
even though people often change
their minds or circumstances
change.
This is where I do
think that there
is some responsibility on the
part of users to take advantage
of the tools that are given to
them if those tools are given
to them in an easy-to-use way.
I encourage everyone
to at least take
a few minutes as
part of your maybe
not daily but maybe
weekly or monthly routine
to do a little digital hygiene.
Search your own name on
various search engines
to see what's coming up.
If you have accounts--
and sometimes you
have accounts even
for only defensive purposes.
So sometimes I get
resistance where
they say, well, I don't want to
sign up for an account for XYZ
because then they'll have even
more information about me,
which I'm sympathetic to.
But if it allows you to then
sort of log in and regularly
delete information or
cleanse information,
then that might be positive.
And then take advantage
of popular add-ons.
I use ad blockers, which
I know is controversial,
but I think that's
another possible tool.
And then finally-- and
this is just the thing
that I throw out generally-- is
if two-factor authentication is
ever offered anywhere,
use it, and use it
sort of early and
often is my example.
But I do think that
vanity searches, learning
how to work within dashboards
is at least a key part.
It can't be everything, right?
My argument is that often users
are being asked to do too much,
but there is some
sort of expectation
that I think we can have of
users to at least sort of try
to exercise some diligence
with the tools that are given.
AUDIENCE: What are your
thoughts on premium options?
So we're starting to
see a lot of companies
moving towards that end.
We have a YouTube premium
option, et cetera,
as a method for coming back
to your concept of control.
Do you see that as valid?
WOODROW HARTZOG: I'm of two
minds for the premium options.
I mean, on one hand I
like the premium options
because the business model
seems a little clearer.
So one of the things that
I've always been drawn to
is when everybody's incentives
are sort of out in the open
and we know sort of what
we're dealing with it,
it becomes a lot easier
and easier to trust.
I think for the
premium models to work,
there has to be not just
some sort of soft promises
but I think really
robust promises.
I would love the
idea of platforms
being able to opt into sort of
the gold standard of privacy,
which is the true level
of trustworthiness where
they say we will be loyal.
We will be discreet.
We will be honest to the
sort of highest standard.
And then that can drive people
to sign up for companies.
It could be a
competitive advantage.
And I've always
longed for privacy
to be a competitive
advantage, and I
think that we're seeing a
little traction on that model.
But then the other side
of me worries a little
about premium models because the
other thing that I worry about
is that privacy
becomes something
only that people that
have affordances can have,
and I really worry about
the sort of equities
where we say if you pay the
gold-standard option you
get privacy.
For everyone that can't afford
it, they don't have that.
And so for that reason, I'm
still actually struggling
with a lot of the way that that
cashes out in terms of policy
because I do worry about that.
AUDIENCE: And we have
one more question
on the Dory from Keith.
What are we all missing
about Dragonfly?
And the context
is a "Wired" story
of Sundar at the "Wired" summit.
WOODROW HARTZOG: So
Dragonfly, as I understand it,
is the initiative for Google
to enter China's market,
right, if I'm understanding
the stories correctly.
And I haven't read
a lot about it,
so I actually can't provide
a nuanced discussion,
but I have thought a lot
about the values they
get reflected in technology.
And so to that extent,
I think it's worth
having an explicit
conversation about what
the affordances of Dragonfly
would be because it doesn't
exist in a vacuum.
This is a browser that will get
deployed within a system that
is actively leveraging things
like social credit scores.
And the social credit
score actually I will say
scares me a lot,
the idea that we
would be ranked based on any
number of different factors
and then have benefits
sort of denied to us based
upon those factors--
that we wouldn't
be able to board
a plane or that we
would have sort of
demerits taken away
from us because we used up too
many rolls of toilet paper.
The fact that we would be
sort of datafying everything,
does this contribute
to that effort,
because that's a value
that's implicated.
Will it help
exacerbate the spread
of facial-recognition
technology, which
is another thing that
I've worried about a lot.
Because in order to gain the
benefits of facial-recognition
technology, of which there
admittedly are many--
we can find the bad guy.
We can find missing children.
We can help those that
don't have the ability
to sense in ways of others.
But in order to get a lot of the
real uses of facial-recognition
technology, not just the sort of
minor conveniences of unlocking
your phone with your face
rather than your fingerprint--
which is fine, but I view
as just a very incremental
benefit--
but in order to get
the real benefits,
we will have to give up
a lot, almost everything.
We have to have
cameras everywhere.
We have to have databases
that are shared.
Facial-recognition
technology depends
upon the existence of a
name-face database that
can recognize people.
And I think we have to think
about that value as well,
and will this aid
that in the aggregate,
and is it worth then defining
the values of the company
based on that because your
values are reflected not just
in what you do but
in what you build.
And I think that it merits
a serious conversation
about the direction of a company
and the ethos of a company
with that creation.
But that being said, I'd be
scared to comment any more
because I actually don't know
the specifics of the project.
AUDIENCE: So terms
and conditions
seems like a necessary evil,
but clearly the way they're done
today is pretty terrible
because nobody reads them,
and now people are I
guess legally bound.
I'm not even sure if they're
legally bind in because nobody
understands them.
Nobody reads them.
Can you agree to
something you don't read?
At least that's the point.
And there's no expectation
to read them either,
which is another issue.
But how do you think that
could be done better?
WOODROW HARTZOG: Great.
Thank you very much.
I love that question.
So I just wrote an essay
a little while back
called "User agreements
are betraying you"
with the idea that it's this
abstraction, nuanced tension,
that's unresolvable.
We could either have--
someone proposed
at some point a 100-word
user agreement, which
that's not even an
advertising slogan almost.
I mean, it's so sort of
abstracted to not really tell
you anything.
I think that user
agreements could
be improved upon if they
are written in a way
that they are written for
basically transparency purposes
because some people
do read them.
Actually there's a really good
article by Mike Hintze called
"In Defense of the Long
Privacy Statement,"
and he says that
some people actually
do read privacy policies.
Regulators do.
Advocates do.
They serve an-- huh?
AUDIENCE: Attorneys.
WOODROW HARTZOG:
Attorneys, right.
Attorneys do.
They serve an important
hygienic function for companies.
So they let you know
like internally like, OK,
here's where all
our information is.
We've got stock of it.
It's an incredibly good
force functioning tool.
It's just not for users.
And so my preference would be
to have a regulatory regime--
and this is a little
controversial--
where there's certain things
that you cannot trade away
in a user agreement.
So in other words, there's a
baseline set of protections
that cannot be compromised
through terms and conditions.
We have this in other
areas of the law.
And then that way
users can agree to them
without worrying about them.
Because I always sort of had
this like small sense of dread
when I click I agree like
I didn't read any of this.
I don't know what's in there,
but I agreed to it anyway.
And they actually are
enforceable, largely.
So the law-- and I teach
contracts sometimes too--
and the law of contracts is
that if you click I Agree,
then courts are going
to say you agreed.
And I would like to
have a talk about things
that are unwaveable so that it
basically didn't matter what
was in the terms of
agreements because they are
important risk-mitigation
tools for companies
and they could have nice
transparency and accountability
aspects to them.
We just have to stop
pretending that they're
for users because the things
that shape users' expectations
are the designs, the website.
It's the padlock icon.
It's the button.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate
it, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]